i want to bring everyone else back on to
the show
one year in lockdown has anyone actually
become a
a better person i have took inventory
and i have not become a better person i
didn't learn
spanish i didn't write something
incredible
has anyone done anything or can i feel
good about myself
i think i did one thing that is really
uncommon during a pandemic i froze my
eggs
oh that's great prosperity and just
no one brushing you yeah and i figure
maybe a couple of years from now i get a
good price for them on the black market
[Laughter]
i did a 20-day water fast yeah i don't
think you should do that did you feel
good
actually right at the beginning of
lockdown i found out i had
lyme disease and i was trying to find
out for the longest time what was wrong
with my ass
yeah yeah and uh i read that it
totally eradicates lime from your body
so i was like i'm doing this
didn't work at all no it made me feel
worse it was really bad but for some
people you know i guess it worked was
there a day that
that was like a wally hit like around
day nine i think in fast where you start
hallucinating or you start i think like
not feeling hungry day 17
around day four you don't feel hungry
but like the first week i was like this
is awesome i have so much energy
and like i'm not hungry and then day 17
i was like
[ __ ] dude and i just kept watching a
bunch of mukbang videos
and masterchef it just made you more
hungry watching the mukbang where people
just like
gorge themselves it like satisfied me
jackie have you done anything
have you learned a new skill at all have
you picked up a musical instrument
well i've played the guitar before and
then got written and forgot about it
even existing and so restrained the
guitar got back into that
um wrote this is so cliche but since we
weren't doing shows
a lot i had time so i like wrote a pilot
so that's cool
learned got me some what is it final
draft learned about how to character
descriptions took
classes on how to do it so that's cool
yeah and then just like lots of therapy
anyone else do that that was i did a lot
of like oh awareness
you know like there's a lot of i'm aware
now so that's good that's what i've been
doing and i can
do a few songs now i can play a few
songs is there something anyone has
narrowed down in their life on that note
of like is there something like oh i
could completely do without this
this is something i thought i needed in
my life but now that i don't have it
oh a space space and clothes space you
don't need just
to live in a big place i don't think
just the app i have a one bedroom and
i'm like
oh i just need this one room like i'm
always just in my living room
how about you guys i think other
people's approval
i feel like on the other end of the i'm
going out doing all kinds of different
outfits
i'm gonna do my hair differently i'm
like already deciding like am i getting
tattoos maybe we do this
like i'm just like ready to to go live
yesterday so
i feel like i'm gonna be taking more
risks i think
fashion wise because i would always be
like this is not what people have been
used to seeing me in
so it'll be a transit no we're not doing
that anymore man this is a bummer
everyone became a better person
learned a skill yeah
certain ways i became really like way
worse like i realized i can't live
without target
[Music]
how was that target like a good amount
of time during the pandemic and i'm
talking about early when
we when it was like no stay at home like
don't go out unless it is absolutely
essential i'm like but i want to smell a
candle
oh like i was at target yeah so
your pitch is to close every small
business
and that's what i learned is i don't
need small businesses i need
stores packed full of people how about
you moses
i think personal space of like i need
this time to be alone i think i need
less of it still some of it is
healthy but i don't need as much as i
thought
you had your fill yeah i'm like oh yeah
yeah none of this is like uh you're not
happy unless you can share it with
someone
and that little sweet thing yeah i get
that i hear them and then the last thing
before we all cry if you could change
one feature about zoom today
you ha and it goes across the board what
would it be
should never have yourself you yes i
don't want to self you
ever i don't care i don't want to see it
leave me alone i would change the mics i
don't like that
when one person speaks it cancels one
other person out i would change
it seems like the system operates on one
major mic if that makes sense
i would i would change that mike okay
yeah the mic the sound on zoom that's a
good one
especially but especially if you're
doing stand-up
you know if every anybody of all we've
all done zoom on stand up
it sucks it's like i didn't realize
until i listened back after like my
first show
when they're still laughing they can't
hear anything that you're saying like
you're completely knocked off the town
because their laughter like dominated
your ten steps
way too close to my going ah
[Laughter]
i was watching one of jackie's stream
and someone was was coughing yeah zoom
comedy is when the laugh
actually becomes a heckle like
definitely we had that a few times where
i was like all right we get you're
enjoying the show but can you do it more
quietly
like that would be cool yeah exactly
jackie what would you pick
i would add a button where the host can
automatically
on like require video to turn on like i
would love to just turn video on when
people when people are hidden i want to
see what they're doing
behind closed doors and i would love to
just be like
beep and then everybody is revealed oh
that would be what a powerful
that
okay so invasion of privacy is what we
selected
i would pick one end meeting button
not the second end meeting that are you
sure you have to
yeah over click because people have
picked their face of like
all right thank you guys so much for
doing the show my name is moses storm
we'll be back
oh totally i hate that thing where
you're like
it's so unattractive you wanna it's cute
you wanna like a good cute
end everything ends that way happy hours
to these shows to like meetings just
like some of them
and you never remember that you have to
do that it's always like you click the
leave meeting and you're like oh yeah i
gotta do this
your eyes wander and it looks weird or
you try to leave on a joke and then it
bombs and you're like all right let me
find that
uh jackie where can people find you just
go to instagram
jackie comedy yeah and then there's
outdoor show coming up if people are in
the bay area
yeah for folks uh it's in half moon bay
it's on april 21st
seven o'clock it is called the new
abnormal comedy show
at the san benito house cantina in half
moon bay
that's fine at zeta have you got both
podcasts honesty with z
just friends and then upload right and
upload yeah and if they want to check me
out on social media it's zaynab johnson
z-a-i-n-a-b
johnson that's great then natalie you
are selling
water pills yes for your new extreme
diet
yeah you can get water pills at my
instagram
at natdogcatdog and you can check out my
podcast
called hidden mickeys yeah and then of
course there's
oh and my special nade on netflix yes
thank you so much definitely
watch that thank you guys so much for
doing the show this was a lot of fun i'm
glad we all got to talk
yes thanks for having me yeah thank you
nice to meet you jackie good to see you
thank you natalie
good to see you thank you natalie moses